[Music]
hey everybody hey welcome to the
interval tonight you guys excited to be
here
what's so excited about capitalism isn't
it's great so great well thank you we're
we're so excited you can be here tonight
with this it's our second talk of the
year we are really excited about 2016
for a lot of reasons one of them is that
we've expanded our audience for these
talks we actually now have an online
audience for those of you who are
members you may know that we have online
streaming for to listen to seminars
we've had that for many years but we've
only just recently started it here at
the interval so hello to everybody at
home they're being wired in upstairs
they're getting your slides in real time
so they can see what's going on and
hopefully we'll get to hear from some of
them in the Q&A as well tonight's talk
is the first of the year that we're
doing with casbahs the Center for the
Advanced Studies in the behavioral
sciences at Stanford if you came to last
year's talk by Fox her Elle or Mary Ann
Woolf then you you know about casbahs
they're a great program that's been
around since 1954 in the social sciences
that brings fellows from all over the
world and happily we're able to borrow
them and bring them you know an hour up
north to speak here in the interval
while they're here so Lewis is the first
of several we're gonna have this year
and we want to give a quick shout-out to
casbahs as well there's some brochures
about their programs there they have
their own speaking Series in Palo Alto
that we recommend you check out as well
without any further ado please give a
big round of applause Louis Hyman from
Cornell via casbahs here to speak
tonight about the New Deal
you don't know
[Applause]
thank you so much for coming out to hear
this little bit about history and to put
things in context now normally when I
talk about the New Deal I like to just
talk about the 1930s I like to talk
about maybe just 1934 that's my
particular my favorite year of the 1930s
but since this is the long now
foundation I was told that one year
wouldn't be long enough that ten years
wouldn't be long enough that 10,000
years was the proper distance of time
but as an overachiever I thought this
was just short term thinking I was like
you people are on the wrong time scale
you need to think about not ten thousand
years but the entire history of humanity
going back a couple hundred thousand
years and if you consider that this idea
of a couple hundred thousand years it
begins to put in context how profoundly
unnatural capitalism is capitalism which
has existed just for about five hundred
years since the dawn of the early modern
is but a blink in the eye of all human
life we take it to be very natural this
is something historians like to bandy
about this term naturalize denaturalize
but all it means is what is natural what
is unnatural what's at stake and the
political idea of something being
natural it's something that we can't
change it's something like gravity it's
something like beauty I don't want
beauties probably historical to I'm a
historian not art historian yeah but but
it's these things that we have no
control over so what I'm talking about
tonight what I'm talking about
capitalism I'm talking about something
that humans have decided on to do and
that a particular moment in time we did
had a tremendous amount of effect and
how it was operating
Malthus if any of you have looked into
the history of economics I was told not
to pass here or this guy would strike me
down so Thomas Malthus a famous 18th
century economist famously wrote that
most of human history there was no
growth in fact there could not be any
growth because as soon as you started to
make more food what would happen your
children would survive you'd have more
sex have more children as we all do when
we eat too much there is the 18th
century things change and then suddenly
gobble up all the excess food so that's
what this graph is this graph of world
GDP per capita this is what the graph is
over here it's not world GDP which is a
measure of all the economic activity but
the world GDP per person now I know if
you're anything like my history students
at Cornell you hate math but a little
math goes a long way so I know how many
of you are frightened of math well with
San Fran's use is a different crowd
y'all are like Pro ok math let's Matt
it's on all right
so if you look at this graph I want you
to look at the years 0 or 1 or whatever
for 67 now 467 dollars per person in the
whole play now do you think that's
totally accurate no probably not but it
gives you a rough whoa don't be touching
my beer all right all right ok this is a
rough sense go to 1000 ad 450 roughly
flat if you extend this grass back
thousands and thousands of years roughly
it would have stayed flat that's
basically the amount of human activity
per person since the dawn of Agriculture
and then something changes something
changes to make Malthus incorrect and
like most historians he imagines the
future through the past so Malthus is
looking
and if that had been the case if nothing
had changed
Malthus would have been correct before
capitalism the 99.7% of all human
history there was very little investment
there was very little technological
change the world of 1450 looked more or
less like the world of zero these
printers and glass blowers look like
technologies that would have been
legible to the ancient Romans and in
fact the largest enterprises in Europe
in this period had 40 people that's the
scale of human endeavor in the moment
before capitalism really emerges and
then suddenly things change things
change
and you get to this graph this very
smooth looking graph now I notice some
of you were nodding your head what do
you notice class about the math of this
graph I want you to notice the very
smooth flat plane until roughly the end
now it looks very flat because the end
the period post 1800 is so vertical it's
very easy to draw this graph even a
robot can do it and it would be easy to
forget that behind this graph are people
and events and choices that made this
growth possible that in fact this kind
of growth wasn't possible at any other
period in hundreds of thousands of years
that humans have existed it's at this
point that you're wondering who I am and
why I'm talking to you
and I was told that I had to give you
some authority for who I am and why I'm
talking to you so briefly I'm going to
tell you a bit bit about me I'm a
historian of capitalism I have written
books several books too on the history
of debt in America on the political
economy and culture as well as a reader
I went to college and then graduate
school at these places then I worked at
these two places McKinsey and Cornell
and now I am at this place and now I'm
done with that I don't care about that
what I care about is something very
special
how many of your drinking tonight all
right yeah drink with me y'all all right
consider the interval now everything you
need to know about capitalism can be
understood through that met
quintessential drink here all right
beer beer is the foundation of all our
thoughts a night are you guys
comfortable drinking will you drink with
me
all right I want you to imagine a
magical machine called the beer machine
it takes water and turns it into magical
delicious beer all right not one that's
for another person but a magical machine
now what would you do with such a
machine if you had such a machine I want
you all to think to yourselves about
what you would do if I give you a
machine that nobody else had that would
turn water in to beer who said that who
said they would party yes
yes you sir are human being all of you
the thought I would I would I would make
a market out of whatever you people do
in the in Silicon Valley that is not
human okay what humans would do if they
had a beer machine is they would share
because what happens if you share beer
with that guy he becomes your friend
right and then what happens you can beat
up nerds that's right so for most of
human history if you have beer or any
other kind of luxury good you share it
with people and become popular and then
make war
this is a very natural kind of situation
you see it all the time at Cornell
University we call it a keg party okay
this is not what capitalism is in
capitalism it is an idea that instead of
sharing you take that excess and you
reinvest it instead of giving away beer
to your friends and then making war upon
your enemies you sell the beer to your
friends and this is very strange for the
very first time this is a schematic
argument and I was given 35 minutes all
right but the so I want you to realize
that humans have always traded there
have always been exchanges between
people but only recently in the last few
hundred years after you were produced
with machines like the beer machine in
order simply to sell it and to exchange
it this is a new novel way of thinking
thinking I have an excess I will sell it
reinvest it get more machines this is a
very weird idea I mean it's through this
very weird idea that we come to the most
important thing about capitalism which
is capital this duality of capitalism
that money capital is money and capita
and capital is also an investment
something that is invested in like a
beer machine now if this were
undergraduates I'd ask you how what
happens in your macroeconomics class and
you'd say oh it's very simple professor
Hyman okay that's my name the you'd say
that's very simple savings equals
investment if there is an excess of
money it simply gets invested in the
world and this is how capitalism works
that's how capitalism is supposed to
work but we are as all people of the
world we know how hard it is to find a
good investment but we do know that what
a capitalist would look like somebody
who would take that excess and invest it
this person about to show you is the
worst example of a capitalist in
American culture
Scrooge McDuck Scrooge McDuck is not a
capitalist why a scrooge mcduck not a
capitalist he is skiing on his money
that is not a very capitalist thing to
do do not acquire a hoard of gold and
then ski upon it he is happy it's true a
bitter capitalist intercepts Andrew
Carnegie who wrote that the great
manufacturing or commercial concern
which does not earn at least interest
upon its capital soon becomes bankrupt
must either go forward or fall behind to
standstill is impossible
The Economist's equilibrium the place of
stasis where savings equals investment
where everything is solid does not exist
in capitalism in some very basic sense
that idea of market equilibrium is
antithetical to what capitalism is the
idea of growth the idea of what Joseph
shown paints are called
creative destruction the idea that
profits inevitably fall in mature
industries and new industries rise up
through the hands of entrepreneurs to
create new sites of investment
overcoming this crisis nerds this is the
great fear of ogre and Revenge of the
Nerds right that these nerds
would come and they'd sell things and
there'd be no more physical power
Oh gore was right to fear them
capitalism offers growth but it also
offers us inequality using money to make
more money it doesn't care whether it's
making beer machines or steel or
consumer debt it's agnostic to the
source of profit where does this come
from this idea of capitalism now it
originates in roughly or the sixteenth
century and to great transformations
discovery well first beginning with
discovery of the new world
the beginning of the African slave trade
which is the European slave trade of
Africans
and the beginning of new kinds of
factories that are organized in England
and then in the u.s. these new kinds of
systems had no new technology they were
just the reorganization of people it's
what historians now call the industrious
revolution rather than the Industrial
Revolution this first stage of
capitalism had no new technology
everything you see here in the early
many factories they had before but they
just did it at home
it's the reorganization of people just
like today with the gig economy now I'm
talking in your language
it's the reorganization of Labor online
no real transformation in what's
happening in its underlying technology
so this is the early phase of capitalism
this is when the graph begins to
basically creep up European slavery but
then there's a breakout and it's here
roughly around 1800 it's this moment
when people begin to realize that it's
not enough to reorganize people and to
invest in production by organizing those
people but to invest in new technologies
to increase productivity to increase
products that can then be sold and it's
this moment that we think of as the
beginning of industrial capitalism this
moment when science for the very first
time is harnessed for greater production
and greater value and this is when
capitalism really really takes off I
want you to keep noticing the scale on
the left side over there because you're
not afraid of math and for the very
first time in all of human history
economic growth per capita economic
growth is faster than people growth we
do not have sex and have children to eat
away all our growth and it's an amazing
amazing transformation what historians
mystically economic historians talk
about is this idea of the leading sector
how do you think about this
transformation how is it not just that
smooth inevitable looking curve and the
idea that you
this idea of the leading sector that
there's one particular area of the
economy that is so profitable that it
pulls and so big that it pulls everybody
thing else in its wake
bringing about new opportunities for
growth new jobs wage growth everything
and at first in the pre-industrial
capitalism of the 18th century you have
cotton sugar and shipping then
industrial capitalism wheat railroad
steel and then in the 20th century cars
and chemistry aerospace and electronics
this shouldn't be that hard this isn't a
crazy idea this is what we see every day
I mean after all how many of you have
BlackBerry's so retro as you come here
in a fixie I bet you did yeah so the
idea so I think that this is a basic
idea that when a product comes out
there's tremendous opportunities or
profits it grows over time and then as
it becomes a mature industry at Falls
and this isn't true just of particular
products like blackberries but entire
industries so there were time the
technology becomes well known and it
becomes a commodity industry this is
just normal ways of thinking now
this leading sectors are very important
because first of all I think it should
be obvious that aerospace is not obvious
that most of us cannot just walk outside
and be like oh let's build a plane cool
it's actually super hard it's very hard
to build a railroad it's very hard to
imagine an industry as complicated as
the electronics industry and so this
transformation is not obvious what that
next leading sector will be and yet so
far we have been able to figure out what
it is finding that new industry that
allows us to bootstrap ourselves into
the next level of growth but finding
that next sector has not been obvious in
the past as it was not in the 1930s as
it was not in the Great Depression
when there is a failure to find that new
leading sector when capital does not
find its way into a sector that can pull
along millions and millions and billions
and billions of people we have a
depression when capital can't find that
place to earn that profit we have a
depression and that's what happened in
the 1930s if you look closely at the
industries of the 1930s after the
initial crisis the crash of the stock
market 29 followed by a crash in the
housing market a couple years later all
the cutting-edge industries like
electronics aerospace they were fine
within six months but they were this big
they were this big more people in the
u.s. worked in candy manufacturing than
in airplanes in the 1930s and all the
big places where we invested all our
capital all our biggest employers sorry
all our biggest employers like cars just
waste it away this stagnation was a
crisis of the failure of capital to get
into these new industries where is
capital in America in the 1930s it was
in banks and capitalists like Amadeo
Giannini the founder Bank of America I
want you to notice that he is not skiing
he is not smiling
he is very he's a very nervous Italian
guy he does not know what to do with all
his money this is a letter more than any
graph I think reveals this anxiety this
is a letter from the citibank archives
between the head of citibank would now
then known as National City Bank and the
Bank of America my dear aap I want to
give you a short report of conditions
here and put before you the city company
situation our excess reserves are very
big it's almost impossible to find any
use for money
in credits that we're willing to take
and the rates are terribly low
too much capital nowhere to put it even
though millions are out of work and
these new industries that we now know
are great investments we are capable of
producing millions of jobs don't have
capital to grow I want you to think
about that now where does the New Deal
fit into all of this we all know that
the New Deal is a bunch of liberals
wasting money right
it's liberals digging holes and filling
them back up and paying people and we're
told this by the face of these two men
FDR Franklin Delano Roosevelt and Harold
Ickes
bureaucrat now when we think about the
New Deal we don't usually think about
innovative investment we do not think
about entrepreneurship and it's because
of this guy on the Left what did he do
he ran the Public Works Administration
various government agencies that took
tax hard-earned taxpayer dollars and
just built dicks they built where they
built it at stadiums where you can see a
picture of it bridges parks and
Fairgrounds school lunches I mean I
guess we should have school lunches but
thisis these are things that we really
like that's good it's important to have
school lunches it's important to have
stadiums and we feel good about it
it's important to save America look they
build dams power America there they they
build this is Libby Montana is anybody
from Libby Montana no well they gave a
great City Hall to Libby Montana all
right look they kept they kept all our
young men beautiful and shaved all right
that's for people who are into a
beautiful young man look at that I can
send you the picture afterwards send me
an email all right keeping our young men
manly not idle look at him there we have
left it to private enterprise we've seen
the results capitalism failed
capitalism bad and every time akise
wrote a check for a new stadium across
the new york times
would splash the headline Aquis urges
billions for larger PWA plan this is one
vision of the response to the depression
spend more create jobs capitalism cannot
work we have total market failure
capitalism was in free fall but
capitalism is not just spending
capitalism is investment not useless
investment but investment in things that
produce new industries that produce
growth and is solutions the solutions
you are all told about in your high
school history classes did not
reinvestment luckily there were other
people in the New Deal that you've not
heard about probably or if you have you
have been told what they really did the
crisis of the New Deal was this crisis
of investment how to get all this
private capital that AP Giannini was
fretting about through the tube where
Uncle Sam was sitting on this hose and
spring it on the garden of recovery now
there's two things I want you to notice
that Uncle Sam has a hose connected to
the capital and that the hose has all
kinds of knots in it and he's standing
on it what they figured out was how to
get that capital onto the garden and the
man that did it was this guy hanging
pretty Jesse Jones on the shoulders of
Harold Ickes
look at that Harold Harold I feel bad
for Harold he did not seem like a lot of
fun Jesse Jones he's a fun guy he was
pure Texas all right yeah they called
him Uncle Jesse
he was six foot three and he was a
multimillionaire
in a time when there weren't many multi
millionaires
he was a risk-taker he owned his own
newspaper he owned he was the lor the
large
real estate developers in America he had
his own bank he was the original
investor what became Exxon this is not
he reaped he built Houston from a land
scam into a port city
needless to say Jesse Jones believed in
the power of entrepreneurialism and the
power of investment and it was Jesse
Jones who thought that Eastern bankers
were too conservative he didn't identify
with these Eastern banking values these
anxieties of whether or not to taste
risk with capital years later in his
autobiography he recounted the fear as
quote the bankers began to hoard they
called in loans they declined to make
loans and in the spreading fright the
aim was simply to convert everything
possible into cash and let the business
of extending credit the lifeblood of
Commerce and Industry takes shelter
until the dark skies had cleared he
recognized that one of the signal
failures of the economy was the fear and
the way in which capital was being
hoarded Jones was a banker and when he
came to Washington as he did initially
under Hoover and then had his position
expanded under FDR he came as a banker
in something that was behind many of the
successful all their parts of the New
Deal the reconstruction Finance
Corporation don't worry there will be no
exam no three of the things I want to
talk about very very briefly it's happy
to talk about more in the qat the first
thing is the FHA the Federal Housing
Administration that I'm certain you've
all heard of it was a program that did
work just like well connecting those
private banks and consumers what it did
was it acted as a middleman the
reconstruction Finance Corporation
borrowing money either directly from
these banks and then lending it to
consumers or creating a market
intermediary in the FHA case that was
Fannie Mae which worked and so very
recently okay but it worked to allow
people in New York City to invest in
Texas to invest in California
it allowed consume
to borrow money at scale for the very
first time the REA which I bet some of
you history buffs might remember from
high school as well the rural
electrification administration when in
the early in 1930 ninety percent of
rural America had no electricity
whatsoever you could tell you were going
from country from city to country by the
darkness that would fall around you and
I said widespread effects you could
Electrify your farms
you couldn't farmers couldn't buy things
they needed of the modern economy and so
what the REA did was instead of giving
money to consumers it set up electrical
cooperatives throughout the country
channeling money again through
intermediary loan systems from the
private capital of Eastern banks and
Western banks into rural America setting
off an incredible agricultural
productivity boom and the third part
which I will buy you a beer if you know
about unless you are a professional
historian Liz the defense plant
Corporation which did the same thing in
the name of sip in the name of defense
but for aerospace and electronics and I
want to talk about this one as the most
technologically sophisticated of all
these areas and so these policies in the
1930s solved the depression not through
government spending but through Uncle
Sam's ability to steer the hose of
capital the totality of all those
stadiums and free lunches and well
shaved young men added together
accounted for about one or two months of
spending all that over many years
through these programs billions of
dollars that were private dollars that
taxpayers didn't pay for that were
simply the movement of capital into
riskier areas that capitalists
themselves were afraid of that they
themselves may profit on was done
through this and so it's through this
public policy that a private good is
created and we created all kinds
new industries that became the
foundation of our post-war prosperity I
want to talk about aerospace for a few
minutes
again more people in 1939 were working
in candy than were working in aerospace
it was the 41st largest industry in
America the entire industry in 1939 made
3,000 planes it's hard to get our heads
around the state of the airplane
industry in the 1930s we're told but in
our books you know that a Kitty Hawk 30
years earlier they had made planes and
they had but it was still kind of a
weird thing it's kind of like the space
plane today how many of you have written
because maybe you have this is Silicon
Valley but this is not a normal
situation right I mean the flight from
New York to Paris that Lindbergh did he
was a hero in 1927 you know he got a
prize for that which was then the
inspiration of course for the Ansari X
Prize in 2004 which gave us the first
space plane now I've never ridden in a
space plane this is the same kind of
situation between the 20s and 30s as the
aughts to now only I do not expect to be
in a space plane in the next two years I
do not expect America to start producing
hundreds of thousands of space planes to
fight space Nazis
now while Lindbergh was celebrated as a
hero I think the real hero were people
who created this whole new industry not
only to fight Nazis which we know from
the internet is evil but because they
created a thing that employed millions
of Americans to created amazing new
technologies and revolutionized
capitalism now the DPC were not a bunch
of Harold Ickes
they were not a bunch of bureaucrats
they were people of the world this is
the worst slide in my presentation it
was too complicated or refused to redo
the boxes but I want you to notice the
people involved the chairman of US Steel
the president of General Motors who by
the way was one of the main inventors of
the assembly line Ralph Budd of the
railroad
but also Sidney Hillman prominent labor
leader Harriet Elliot the Dean of the
University of North Carolina these were
people who stepped out of their social
millou's stepped out of their politics
extreme left extreme right came together
and figured out public policy they would
connect that private capital with the
public interest
this isn't creating a workers utopia
this is creating the closest we've ever
come in American history the post-war
prosperity what did they do in just a
few years they created an industry they
had an that was four times the size of
the pre-war auto industry so it went
from something where more candy was
being made to something larger than the
largest industry in America in just a
few years consider the amount of
imagination that took organizing the
people behind it connecting the dots and
yet they did it they built a thousand
airfields imagine the scale doing that
there were 28 before the war a thousand
airfields and then they turn them over
to private to the private sector so that
there could be a post-war aerospace
industry Detroit supplied the engines
but they built these new plants
everywhere Tulsa Los Angeles and this
was something that I think I'm just so
inspired by that 40% of Los Angeles was
working for the aerospace industry by
the end of the war 2.1 million people
all done without government money Curtis
Wright becomes second only to General
Motors
in corporate size in just a few years I
just want you to think about the scale
of this transformation millions and
millions and millions of people billions
of dollars it's a wild reorientation the
economy this is a list of the different
companies that were involved
Alcoa Jandra motors US Steel this isn't
a bunch of startups this is big
corporate capitalism it's the amount of
money on the right
did they invest it in these different
areas three billion dollars in 1945 now
you're probably wondering what is that
today I wish I had a slide that said
that boom all right this is how much
money that would be today forty two
billion dollars fifteen billion dollars
into steel fourteen billion dollars into
synthetic rubber
yes there was no since then synthetic
rubber industry before the DPC this
created that can we do that in America
today can we imagine ourselves into a
new economy new industries we employ
millions of people can we build the
space planes of tomorrow can we find the
money where would all this money come
from there is enough money we were
always told what would be something like
this today a keys of curse was furious
they were abandoning New Deal ground
this was just giving money to capitalist
into corporations and he was right but
with a particular purpose created jobs
created guns fight Nazis and those
profits were limited by windfall tax
laws and so channeling this private
capital rebuilt the economy and for me
at least I think this is an excellent
model for thinking about how to promote
innovation entrepreneurship and
technological change in our economy
today it's not one silver bullet it's
three different silver bullets for
organizing local banks for organizing
local cooperatives for organizing
monopolies and today I think we need it
I think we need it does it feel like a
return to prosperity these two happy
gentlemen will tell you different and we
can see it in our politics that we're
told oh no no the unemployment rate it's
only 5% why are you so unhappy world
America you have jobs now the recovery
is over yet this number conceals a lot
this number it conceals a lot
and again you told me you were
comfortable with math so I want you to
look at this scale 2005 to 2015 at the
beginning unemployment's around 5% at
the end it's 5% shut up go get a job but
there's a story behind them about labor
force participation unemployment is the
number of people looking for work in the
last two weeks that if that have not
been a find it
this story is people who are in the
workforce and that's a very different
story that's a number going from about
66 percent to about 63% of people who've
just given up since the Great Recession
this is actually pretty stunning if you
go a little further back to 1990 you can
see it going up and down cycles the
economy and then you see the precipitous
collapse after the Great Recession and
if you begin to add these together my
squiggling number like scratching on
slides all right that's the difference
there we go I'll keep that in our heads
that's when you add the squiggle on top
okay I did it I put it together all
right but basically 3.5% of the
workforce is dropped out since the Great
Recession add that to the unemployment
and we have not had a job recovery 8% of
people are without work we're being told
everything's great and it's not our
biggest firms our most exciting areas
are just exciting companies like these
Google and Goldman Sachs and like I love
I love Google I love Google
I love Google but nobody works there
alright my sister does but otherwise
nobody really works there more people
work at Sears 10 times as many people
work at Sears as work at Google I think
in San Francisco it's hard to keep that
in our heads the difference between who
we're excited about all he we know who
work in tach and the scale of it
actually impacting the economy and the
difference is pretty intense the biggest
firms we have employ hardly anyone and
do nothing to soak up all that capital
I'm sure all of you have heard about how
easy is to have a start-up these days
tend to be in capital light investment
this is that world so what would that
big question mark be today now I am a
historian I am NOT an industrialist if I
were an industrialist I wouldn't be here
tonight but there's two things we know
we want that to look like we know that
we want to have capital flowing into
small and medium sized businesses
nowadays it's nearly impossible for a
small business that's not a start-up
that's just a plumbing supply company
that's been profitable or a cheese shop
that wants to grow but can't get
investment it's impossible for banks to
them to get commercial loans I'll show
you in a second why that is at the same
time it's very hard to get our biggest
corporations to really take risks to
focus and inventing new leading sectors
like Alcoa did like curtiss-wright did
in the post-war period but is there
money is there money to do this do we
have capital somewhere the answer is yes
we do we have a lot of money current
government regulations require about 98
billion dollars to be in the books of
our banks we have a little more than
that we have two point four trillion
dollars in excess of our reserves I
think that's a lot of money you could do
a lot of work with that money if that
money got invested into businesses what
does that mean terms
scale it's about two-thirds of the
entire federal budget that is a lot of
money just sitting there just like it
did in the Great Depression but where do
banks have their money their money's
already tied up in risky business
ventures they don't want anymore
is that the case no that's also not the
case this is a graph of business loans
and consumer loans I checked this 16
different ways I couldn't believe it
when I saw this that right now
consumer debt is around three and a half
three and a half trillion and this is
this is business loans this is like
negligible it's like a few hundred
billion dollars 97 percent less I don't
know about you but this is not how
capitalism is supposed to work those are
supposed to be flip-flopped
that's how economies grow it'll grow
through consumer debt but if you're
curious about how this happened is a
book then I wrote called borrow that I
can tell you about how that happened
but basically the idea is that it became
much easier to securitize all this
consumer debt to bundle it up and sell
it on capital markets than it is for
business debt in fact it's not possible
really to do that now and in fact our
largest government agency that's
supposed to be in charge of doing this
doing what we imagined what what the
reconstruction Finance Corporation did
in the negativities
the Small Business Administration does
hardly any of it
so 15 billion dollars this is this is
like a drop in the bucket compared to
either the size of banks or even the
entire market for small business loans
if you include real estate why is this
it's because we had government policies
in the 1960s and 70s that made it
possible to securitize consumer debt to
make it easier for banks
and lenders and investors to put money
into your credit cards that into your
small business then into even your large
business and this is from a report from
the Federal Reserve report to Congress
why it's not possible to do this now I
think if it's possible to high Greek
debt by goldman sachs if it's possible
for all those wizards of Wall Street to
do all the magic they do every day we
can probably do for small business debt
what we did for houses in Texas in the
1930s before they had computers or you
know anything really they're just
primitive they're cavemen it's in Texas
that's point one point two it would not
fix the new leading sector how do we
find this new leading sector for
instance we're all excited about
self-driving cars who did say about
self-driving cars I'm excited about
self-driving cars I ain't driving I like
sleeping and reading now this will
create a lot of demand I'm very excited
this is a good thing it'll create a lot
of demand though not just for the cars
or replace or lower cars but also the
rebuilding of our cities the rebuilding
of our entire built environment around
these cars a lot of connections a lot of
growth this is the kind of thing that
could be part of a new leading sector it
is the right direction now the other
thing I want to talk about with that is
that sounded crazy how many years ago
two three years ago if I was here five
years ago I was like hey I'm digging a
self-driving car like yeah good luck
with your rocket boots and yet it's
possible it's a failure of imagination
in fact we see this all the time in our
society a failure of imagination which
stems from a basic failure of science
which can we come back to we live in an
era that is not disruptive but
incrementalist bear with me most of the
science we build a technology on the
basic scientific principles electricity
quantum mechanics our results in
products they've been refined since the
1960s
since the 1950s even a lot of ways
incremental list they know been just
been note this room basically would look
the same 50 years ago whereas 50 years
before that none of it would exist we
think we live in a time of technological
change but it's actually relatively slow
because we have cut off imagination and
we've cut off innovative science now a
good test of what a new leading sector
would be does it sound as crazy as a
self-driving car what are some of the
kinds of crazy things you could imagine
in the future I named rocket boots no
sound totally insane I want to point out
one thing that also sounded 10 years ago
when I was talking about this with my
wife and we were in grad school I was
like self-driving cars and space
elevators space elevators right
those sound crazy right yeah a big strip
of material into space with an elevator
attached that's ludicrous but imagine
what it would be like it's the right
order of thinking something totally
totally new applied from further
industries radical new materials science
and most importantly millions and
millions of jobs as a platform for new
possibilities and again I am NOT an
industrialist I am NOT a scientist even
so I have no stake in this if this
happens I will not make any money I
would not even be allowed in space
because my wife thinks I'm gonna die
there okay now this is the right order
of thinking okay it's not a coincidence
that the companies that create the
greatest innovation right now that are
starting to my my experience my feeling
we actually restart this process are the
ones that are monopolies just like in
the post war with Bell Labs this idea of
competitive capitalism actually chokes
out the possibility for real innovation
and that's one part of it but it's also
the problem of science funding we hear a
lot about the 99% and the 1% well this
is the 1% we don't talk about which is
the less than 1% of the federal budget
that goes into science research
in America none of which goes to
historians I have no skin in the game
here but 31 billion dollars the NIH
eight billion dollars to the NSF
supporting the entire scientific
enterprise of our nation supporting all
the possibility for new science that
allows for new sites of investment to
allow capitalism to continue to grow to
create prosperity we need new science to
create new capitalism we new scientists
to create new science but right now
because it's impossible to get grants
every young scientist you know is going
to work on Wall Street all the young
scientists are going to work in
consultant when I started to work at
McKinsey I went I was talking to a guy
and I'm like what did you do before you
came here and I was like what do you do
here he's like I do he's like oh I
invented a fifth state of matter
I was the MIT team that extracted the
bose-einstein condensate that sounds
awesome right I was like that's awesome
I'm like you're awesome I just write
down things that happened before and he
was like and I'm like what are you now
man he's like oh I do
business-to-business pricing and I was
like something has gone horribly wrong
replicate this a thousand times over no
one becomes a scientist because they
want to make money all right maybe a
couple of people do but mostly they want
to be scientists this is a real problem
for everybody so what should we do we
need to get our scientists back in labs
not on Wall Street we need to move away
from short-term profits to long-term
investment we need to move away from
consumer debt to business lending we
need you science again we need to
believe and imagine a capitalism that
can include everyone and so what the
entrepreneurs of the New Deal recognized
was that it wasn't a smooth curve this
curve was not inevitable
this curve was made by people made by
choices made by imaginations and so
today as we think about how to reframe
the economy we need to not worry
about a little percentage in the
unemployment there or a little
percentage here or that interest rate of
this because the economy is not made by
economists the economy is made by people
who can imagine a different world by the
Jesse Jones is and all the people who
worked in these post-war firms the story
of the New Deal that I told you tonight
about how the New Deal reinvented
capitalism has been written out it's
been written out of our histories
because a statist liberal left does not
want to talk about anything that impedes
their spending and on the right the
right has forgotten how important is to
have the state overcome risk to act
together with the state and invest in
the future and I think America has a
great potential and certainly capitalism
is a great engine for growth and we
wanted it to work for us not work us
over and so we need to make it work for
the next 500 years much less the next
10,000 years and to do that we need to
recognize that's an engine for growth an
engine for inequality but also an engine
that needs a little tune-up every now
and again thank you so much for having
me tonight
[Applause]
it's pretty good beer right it's super
tasty the beer is not free here I
apologize for the unnatural state Thank
You Louis that's that's great so we'll
get a couple quick questions we've got a
little bit of time for questions first
off I want to just take a moment to talk
about what you're working on now cuz
you're you're here you're casbahs right
now you're working on a new I'm writing
a new book it's called temp the deep
history of the gig economy so I'm trying
to write a history of how we all became
flexible workers and how this world of
stable work and stable investment went
away and the winners and losers in this
story and what we can do to make that
possible to keep this growth curve going
and and I know you're here and face it
at Stanford at Casbah so you're getting
to talk to some amazing people do you
want to yeah if anybody here is in the
HR department of a large tech
corporation I would like to talk with
you or not but yeah I'm talking to
amazing people and it's wonderful how
open people are on the west coast to
really solving problems and that's
something I've noticed while being out
here for the last you know six months so
what what questions has got a question
in the audience right there so just to
repeat the question folks at home can
hear it so what was the mechanism that
the capital was moved yeah there was
legislation the legislation an executive
order but basically empowering the RFC
the reconstruction Finance Corporation
to run experiments and so actually one
of the most amazing things what FDR was
not that he was very he wasn't very
smart right I mean he's generations of
plutocrats breeding right but he was a
great experimenter he allowed lots of
different things to happen and that's
really what was amazing about FDR
empowering people like Harold Ickes to
do his thing to build stadiums right and
to keep young men employed but also
empowering people who believed in a
different vision of how to repair the
economy and if you want to I can talk at
length about the actual instrument so
basically it was a system by which banks
and lenders would have their principal
guaranteed
by a collective pool of insurance so
that if something defaulted they would
get back the original principle in a
series of bonds rather than the
immediate payments so it made them have
skin in the game but it also allowed
them to take risks in ways they wouldn't
have done ordinarily by Collective
insurance and and I should mention on
the topic of capitalism dude do we still
have any of Lewis's books in the back we
got we got a few of you we have Lewis's
books Lewis is gonna stick around so you
can buy his book if you'd like we have a
few copies
let's make great gifts also they're
great for starting fires so whatever you
want to do with the book is your
business so you can kind of go either
way either way yeah you're like you
really need that satisfaction
so the question so we hope you'll stick
around and he'll be able to answer more
questions afterwards why don't we you do
have any questions on the side of the
room I'll run down the stairs there at
the bottom so so the question so we
marry well I
so the question from a creative is yeah
why are all the dummies the ones that
become billionaires and are there any
smart people that serve in academia I
know a lot of poor smart people I don't
know I I don't think that's the whole
story
I'm sure there's smart billionaires I've
never met a billionaire maybe you're a
billionaire
there's billionaire in the crowd no okay
but I think that feeling of frustration
is what you're really speaking to right
that it seems random
it seems like they're just taking
advantage of an accident of history I
think there has been a lot of that
feeling and a question of alright what
are they going to do with all this money
are they just going to you know do rails
of coke or are they going to provide for
Society in some serious way
right and it's not like Andrew Carnegie
was really giving back when he invent
like open libraries but his workers had
to be at the factory when the library
was opened during the week all right so
it's not like people in the past were
like really wonderful who were super
wealthy but it's something that you know
we should figure out how to create
industries that create jobs whereas
these billionaires its equity
billionaires really aren't creating lots
and lots of jobs this is the problem
that the money is sloshing around
looking for a place to go it's
going into these things that create
filters for your camera to take pictures
of stuff this is not the same as a
railroad
so a couple question I know your focus
is on us capitalism yes primarily I'm a
naval gazer so call me in the field but
but I'm curious to the extent that
you're tracking things another country I
mean one question that comes to mind as
we're talking about instant billionaires
is like the Russian situation or are
there other places is would you say that
however scribe tonight what you've
described tonight is typical of what's
happening in other countries as well or
are there is there are there countries
where they're investing in technologies
and industries in a way they have things
I think that there's been an export of
the US model of austerity and a u.s.
vision of how corporations should be
organized the place it's not doing this
that's the most antithetical it's
perhaps Germany a place that really
invests in its workforce that has
invests in the future that creates
policies that believe in long term
return rather than short-term profit but
I think what's really going to happen
they make that really change it's people
have to stand up as a collective whole
demand political action but also
honestly billionaires that aren't stupid
there's a few that to stand up and say
look I believe in a different kind of
economy and I don't need the money
anymore and it's not just about charity
going to Africa and then even though you
know nothing about Africa I'm not naming
names you know so I think that this is
the question right like how do we
empower them so one of the things to
sort of tie that together then is the
the private investment in space as an
example Ram so that's does that take the
place of the government could you could
that come forward and lead could that
become a leading industry maybe you'll
buy private I mean I I feel like right
now it's great if it can happen private
but places where it's not happening like
the space elevator or I don't know other
stuff I don't know I'm I study the 1930s
I'm really excited about the latest
Myrna Loy film so yeah and I don't know
about other countries that I mean
there's other people here as an academic
I'm reticent to talk about other
things I don't know about one one last
question I hear on the second are the
international scene image of a Los
Angeles that's 40% aerospace jobs
working these great big factories is so
compelling yeah you fast forward 50
years there are many and we really did
invent a new sci-fi technology right we
take it for granted now but this is
bonkers science fiction sure and it
originally began in the 60s let the
record state that the new sci-fi
technology is a mobile phone sure new
leading sector but the LA where 40% of
the jobs are part of this this amazing
sector is in China and so how do you
solve that puzzle yeah are you so when
when capital is international in that
way how does this play out even if we do
into something so when capitalism is
international that way how does I just
kind of get the traction to have the
effects that you're you're talking about
so so how does this what happens in
cellphones in China so the interesting
thing about China is that even in China
most people are not working in
manufacturing even though there's
urbanites are coming in from rural
districts you know where they don't
really have like all kinds of rights
because of that to work at Foxconn they
don't have even their manufacturing is
not driving things really it's just
search for cheaper and cheaper labor so
it's not the same thing is we even have
a new technology we require lots of
people because we haven't automated yet
we haven't been able to figure out how
to get a machine to do what a human can
and that's what really requires people
that's what creates all the jobs
something it's so novel you can't
automate it yet and so cellphones are
awesome I love my cell phone I wake up
and I go to sleep with it next to my
face I give it a sweet smooch smooch but
it is also the transistors in this the
science is not novel except for maybe
the screen Corning Corning no the only
part I'm impressed by his Corning which
makes the glass Corning got hammered for
the last 40 years in its stock price
because it actually invested in research
and development it believed in science
and so a company like Corning is now
paying off big-time now impressed by
cell phones I'm just saying it's not
like the invention of antibiotics
it's not the same as the invention of
the car right so like I'm just asking
for a little you know pushback on the
cellphone being the best thing ever all
right so so we're gonna wrap it last
thing though you have a talk coming up
in April like has bus that we've got
pamphlets from casbahs at the back you
can grab one yes you want to just it's
almost a future of work in the
Anthropocene on the how we envision work
changing in an era of ecological change
with my colleague Natasha Eskander there
so yes so if you want to come to that
please do a totally different topic
totally from talk that's that's free
it's down at casbah sand it's in April
again but no beer back
BYO just whiskey alright one more big
round of applause thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you